(フッ)
我々には、限界がある
人が一生のうちに与えられた時間は
まぎれもなく有限だ
それゆえに！
「不可能」
不可能を可能にする場所！
ピロン♪
それはどこか？
それはこの世界には無い
我々人類が！
ある瞬間にしか到達することは出来ない
想像のユートピア
人はそれを！
「夢」
と言う
夢！それは！睡眠中に！
ぺぺぺぺぺっぺぺえぺぺぺぺぺぺぺぺ
ぺっぺけぺぇ＾＾＾＾＾＾
また！（乳首登場）
睡眠中にもつ幻覚の事である！
夢では主に、その人の願望や願いを見ることがあると言われ...（カンペ登場）
時にはその逆である
悪夢を見ることもある
そう！
夢は、我々ではコントロール出来ない！
不確かなものである！
だがしかし...
時代は変わった！！！！
今では、我々人類はぁ～！
最新のテクノロジーを駆使し
自分の夢をコントロール出来るようになったのだー！！！！
ﾊｧ↑HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆
ﾊｧ↑HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆
ﾊｧッ↑↑HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆HA☆
はぁ～
...
カンペ見ているnow♥
・・・っし完璧。
ハイ、というわけで寝る寸前はじめしゃちょーです
まあ今言った通りですよ
皆さん夢、見たことありますか？
なんか僕もねぇ
よく変な夢見るんですよ
なんか僕願望とか
こうありたいみたいなことが
夢に出るんじゃ無くて
なんだろ、なんか僕の記憶
の脳裏に焼き付いてる
ことがよく夢になります
わかんないんだよななんか
おもちゃ屋さん？
トイザらスみたいなおもちゃ屋さんですごいなんか
争いというか
銃の撃ち合いとかしたこともありますし
すっげー昔のなんか
戦争をしてたぐらいの時期の古い家にいるような夢を思い出したりするんですよ、たまに
前世かな？
...いや前前前世だわ
うるせーわ
はいというわけで皆さん色んな夢を見ると思うんですけども
今回は
たまたまAmazonを触ってたらすげぇものを見つけたんで買ってしまいました
こちら！
なんかアイマスクなんですけど
これ凄いんですよね
こわっ…これ大丈夫かな
これヤバッ、これヤバイなこれ
あんまりちょっと見せちゃダメだなたぶん
コピー複製配布厳禁って書いてあります
そんなにぃ？
これ内容見せられないんですけども
これですね「ｒｅｍｅｅ（レミー）」っていうらしいんですけど
ええぇぇ？？（疑）
マジかこれヤバいよこれ
いや怖い怖い怖い
なんかヤバイこと書いてあるんだけど
すごい・・なんか夢についてめっちゃ書いてありますよ
夢で旅行するとか書いてあります
いやマジなんですってこれ
これ本当にそういうこと書いてあるんですよ（汗）
見てみますか実際に
これ英語読める人ならわかると思うんですけどマジでなんかそれっぽいことが書いてあります
火星？火星？！
「Ｍａｒｓ」って火星だよね
実物がこれなんですけど
これは・・・コピー大丈夫書いてないよね、書いてない
すぅごいよ？
これ堂々と書いてありますからね
見たい夢を見られるアイマスク・レミー
日本正規代理店
...？！
え、そんな高かったっけ！？
ヤバイヤバイヤバイ
えこわいこわいこわいこわいこわいこわい
こわいよこわい怖くなってきちゃった
えぇ？
ガチっぽいですね
ひとまずマジで見たい夢をみられるっていうことを謳ってます
うわなんかヤバイ
えなにこれヤバイよ
なんか脳みそのデータとか取られたりしないよね？（？）
電子機器がつまってます
えっ俺なんか脳の記憶とかメモリ取られたら嫌なんだけど（ありません）
実践者の96%の方が効果を実感って書いてありますから
えっ・・あっあっあっあっ点滅した
点滅した
点滅したキタキタキタ
この光をつかってたぶん夢をコントロールするんでしょうね
うぅん？
ホントかなこれ？
あやしいなぁ！？（疑）
ひとつめが「ロー」
これが「ミディアム」
これが「ハイ」って三種類の強度があるみたいです
大丈夫かななんか洗脳とかされないかな？？？
というわけでみなさん
僕今から寝るんですけども
見たい夢を見てこようと思います
寝ますよもう寝ます
あぁ僕の見たい夢は・・・
ほんとに純粋に見たい夢を見ますよ
・・・その夢をみたいなと思って僕は今から寝ます
キタキタキタキタ・・・
わぁこれで始まるのか
これでもういつでも夢に入れるらしいです
じゃあさっき見たい夢がこれで見れるのかどうか検証していきたいと思います
また明日報告しますね
じゃあおやすみ～・・・
はじめナレ）彼は果たして・・・どんな夢を見ているのだろうか・・・
ｸｫｧｯｹｺｩｫｯｺｫｫｫｫｫｫｫ↑↑↑↑
ﾃﾛﾛｯﾃﾛﾛｯ･･･
ﾃﾛﾛｯﾃﾛﾛ･･･
ふわぁ・・・
あれ・・・？
俺の見た夢は・・・
俺の見た夢は・・・？
あっ
何も覚えてねぇや☆
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓
さて問題です
はじめんは今回の動画の冒頭部分で何回HA☆と笑ったでしょうか？
thinking time...
正解は・・・
23回でした☆